[Musique]
toutes les augmentations de tarifs de
l'énergie qui sont mises en place
actuellement en déstructurant ses
services publics et en les ventes
d'armes au privé sont qu' il y à des
augmentations très importante qui
grèvent le budget des retraités malgré
toutes les promesses qu'on entend depuis
quelques années les salaires
ne sont pas convenables au niveau de
l'hôpital dans toutes les catégories de
personnel à la richesse se crée ce sont
les travailleurs qui l'a créé
aujourd'hui avec 236 milliards accumulés
pendant la crise de la pandémie depuis
le début par les actionnaires c'est à
dire quatre fois le budget de l'hôpital
on sait très bien qui a largement de
quoi augmenter les salaires
[Musique]